[Música]
no estamos para experimentar cuántas
veces hemos oído decir esto algún
político en campaña presidencial en
algún debate en alguna entrevista pues
saben que yo creo que no pueden estar
más equivocados les voy a demostrar por
qué pero que es experimental la
experimentación es una de las fases del
método científico ese que nos enseñaron
en la escuela y consiste básicamente en
probar varias maneras de resolver algo
experimentamos para validar o refutar
las hipótesis para entender los
fenómenos o para encontrar las mejores
soluciones a una serie de retos
complejos y aquí en el país tenemos un
montón de problemas súper complejos que
no hemos logrado resolver a través de
los años
por ejemplo el combate a la pobreza
tenemos más o menos 20 años de estar
estancados en el 20% de la población
bajo bajo la línea de pobreza
o por ejemplo que me dicen del problema
del desempleo estructural año con año
tenemos a miles de muchachos graduándose
de carreras que no son las que está
demandando el mercado o peor aún
estudiando carreras que ya no van a ser
necesarias en los próximos años la
automatización robótica o la
inteligencia artificial va a cambiar
radicalmente la dinámica laboral lo que
me dicen de las movilidades y el
transporte si ya hoy duramos entre hora
y media y dos horas para varios de
heredia sanjosé cuánto vamos a hablar en
diez quince o en veinte años si año con
año la flotilla vehicular crece a un
ritmo mucho mayor de que podemos crear
una infraestructura pública o un
problema que lo personal me preocupa un
montón el sistema de pensiones si ya hoy
tenemos nuevo sistema de pensiones que
va a pasar en 35 años cuando me meto que
presionar me va a haber recursos va a
haber un modelo sostenible quienes lo
van a sostener si la pirámide
poblacional se está invirtiendo si yo
les dijera que no sólo no tenemos las
respuestas a estos problemas sino que
para grabar más la cosa el principal
actor responsable de ayudar a resolver
estos problemas el que tiene la mayoría
de los recursos el mayor contratista en
el mundo
el que emite la política pública y tiene
la institucionalidad es además el actor
más lento el más pesado el más tieso el
más burocrático de todos y es que
durante décadas hemos sobre normado y
sobre estructura del estado lo hemos
convertido en una maraña
interinstitucional súper compleja es
todo lo contrario de lo que se requiere
para innovar uno para innovar necesita
espacios abiertos flexibles informales
irreverentes y en el estado parece que
las palabras experimentación son como
malas palabras más bien entonces vean
qué complejo por un lado tenemos un
montón de problemas súper complejos que
se van a grabar año con año y por otro
lado tenemos un estado que no está
pensado para adaptarse rápidamente a los
cambios del entorno para innovar
entonces la pregunta en este momento es
y ahora qué hacemos cómo vamos a
resolver estos problemas pues yo tengo
unos 10 años pensando en cómo resolver
esto y encontré una respuesta en la
innovación social la innovación social
tiene como una manía por encontrar las
mejores ideas propuestas soluciones
métodos
para resolver problemas de maneras que
sean mucho más eficientes sostenibles y
escalables las maneras anteriores y es
así que la innovación social ha venido
impactando en diferentes sectores tratan
de generar siempre el mayor impacto
posible uno de sus sectores es el sector
de las organizaciones sociales y la
innovación social se dio cuenta que
había un montón de ongs tratando de
resolver problemas pero de maneras que
no eran suficientemente sostenibles o
escalables dependían de donaciones de
dinero de filantropía no tenían modelos
para escalar estas soluciones y
llevarlas a más poblaciones
entonces vino la innovación social y
dijo qué tal si tomamos las mejores
prácticas del mundo de los negocios
tomamos prácticas de comercialización de
productos y servicios estrategias
comerciales y las ponemos a disposición
de las organizaciones sociales para que
puedan generar modelos mucho más
sostenibles y escalables y así surgió el
concepto de las empresas sociales que
son básicamente organizaciones sociales
que utilizan modelos de negocio
comercializan productos y servicios y
esos productos con los recursos que
generan los invierten en las causas
sociales que quieren resolver
pero ahí no acaba la historia aquí es
donde se pone realmente interesante esa
parte se conoce como emprendimiento
social el emprendimiento social es
básicamente la orientación de la
innovación social hacia el mercado
entonces la innovación social se dio
cuenta que podía generar mucho impacto
con los emprendimientos sociales pero ni
todo ese impacto junto sumado puede
equipararse el impacto que podemos
generar si logramos realmente innovar el
estado hacemos que las instituciones
públicas sean mucho más ágiles más
flexibles y más dinámicas entonces vino
otra vez la innovación social y dijo qué
tal si hacemos otra vez lo mismo que
hicimos con el sector de organizaciones
sociales solo que esta vez tomamos las
mejores prácticas del mundo empresarial
para innovar y para diseñar productos y
servicios para entender las necesidades
de los usuarios y las ponemos a
disposición del sector público
influenciando lo que se conoce como
innovación pública y así fue como surgió
el concepto de los laboratorios de
innovación pública
como estos espacios para traer las
mejores prácticas del mundo empresarial
para innovar y rediseñar la manera como
está funcionando el sector público en
general estos laboratorios de innovación
pública son una de las principales
tendencias en el mundo en estos momentos
los hay en mexico en chile en dinamarca
en españa en corella en australia en
sudáfrica por todas partes los gobiernos
nacionales y los gobiernos locales se
están dando cuenta de que necesitan este
nuevo tipo de instancia para ayudar a
mejorar la manera como funciona el
estado para empezar a destrabar esa
sobre normatividad y sobre
estructuración que hemos generado y trae
mejores prácticas de innovación ustedes
se preguntarán bueno pero que es
exactamente el laboratorio de innovación
pública es este como un fablab o es como
un laboratorio de investigación de una
universidad o es como un laboratorio de
emprendimiento pues no hay ninguno de
esos pero tiene un poquito de cada uno
los laboratorios de innovación pública
son básicamente espacios de diseño
experimental que funcionan como
plataformas colaborativas donde se pone
a disposición de las instituciones
públicas
las mejores prácticas del mundo de
innovación y diseño prácticas
relacionadas a modelos de design
thinking o ciencias conductuales e
innovación abierta línea estará entre
otras para que ahí las instituciones
públicas puedan probar puedan testear
puedan experimentar las iniciativas los
programas los servicios públicos que
todos recibimos de la política pública
en general
antes de escalarla a mí me gusta decir
que estos laboratorios de innovación
pública son como puentes conectan a la
ciudadanía a los empresarios a los
emprendedores a los innovadores con la
complejidad del estado y además como
puentes que hablan ambos idiomas son
como puentes traductores entonces
permiten que fluyan las mejores ideas
propuestas o soluciones para que juntos
y estas palabras clave podamos crear una
nueva política pública y una nueva
manera de funcionar decimos que para los
funcionarios públicos estos laboratorios
son como un espacio seguro donde ahí
pueden probar pueden testear pueden
equivocarse saliendo un poco de la
contingencia un poco más rígida del
estado
e involucrarse en procesos de innovación
pública estos laboratorios están
generando soluciones en todo el mundo
por ejemplo el dj berzins einstein en el
reino unido se especializa en
metodologías de ciencias de
comportamiento humano y han demostrado
que pueden ayudar a aumentar la
recaudación de impuestos utilizando
estos tipos de modelos vean este caso
tomaron un grupo de personas que eran
morosos de impuestos y le hicieron una
serie de mensajes específicos en las
cartas que les enviaban para cobrarles
impuestos a un primer grupo le dijeron
que las personas en su localidad ya
habían pagado impuestos con eso lograron
aumentar la recaudación en dos puntos
versus un grupo de control al que no le
decían nada de esto a otro grupo le
decían que las personas que tenían una
deuda similar a la de ellos ya había
pagado impuestos con esto lograron
aumentar en tres puntos versos del grupo
de control y otro grupo le decían las
dos cosas al mismo tiempo y con eso
lograron aumentar en cinco puntos varios
del grupo de control utilizando este
tipo de mensajes y haciendo alusión a
otras convenciones sociales como que
eran parte de una minoría que no pagaba
impuestos o que el hecho de que no
pagaban impuestos hacía que hubiera
menos recursos para caminos para
escuelas o para el sistema de salud
logró adelantar la recaudación de más de
200 millones de libras en el reino unido
pero eso no solo está pasando en europa
en américa latina' el laboratorio de
gobierno de chile es uno de los
principales referentes en el mundo está
generado más de 40 innovaciones públicas
en el estado chileno y el primer
experimento que hicieron fue tratar de
entender por qué se hacían las filas en
el sistema de salud más o menos según un
homólogo como lo que sería un país
nuestro o una clínica de salud tomaron
ingenios industriales e ingenieros en
servicios sociólogos y se dieron cuenta
de algo interesantísimo había gente
sobre todo adultos mayores que iban y
hacían fila porque no tenían con quién
hablar estaban solos en la casa esto
implica entender realmente las
necesidades del usuario y entender que
todos nosotros somos clientes de las
instituciones públicas y que estamos que
los servicios estén diseñados para
realmente satisfacer las necesidades
otro caso interesantísimo se dio en
sudáfrica allá una organización que se
llama ideas 42 que se especializa en
metodologías de ciencia del
comportamiento humano y ha trabajado
todo el mundo se les ocurrió que darle
una lotería para disminuir los
accidentes de tránsito seguirán en que
tiene que ver una cosa con la otra pues
se les ocurrió que cualquier persona que
tuviera una licencia de conducir está
automáticamente participando ganarse
cuatro mil dólares lo único que tenía
que suceder era que entre el día que
empezaba la lotería y el día que
terminaba no tuvieran ninguna infracción
ninguna multa por exceso de velocidad ni
nada similar algo como eso lo
descalificaba completamente y sólo con
eso lograron disminuir en 40 la cantidad
de muertes en carretera en relación al
año sin lotería al año con lotería
imaginen las cosas que podríamos hacer
aquí en costa rica
no sé si sabían pero este problema
representa el 1,2 por ciento del pib
según un estudio la universidad de costa
rica es más o menos el presupuesto anual
que tiene el motor yo estoy seguro que
aquí podemos hacer cosas súper
interesantes pero tenemos primero que
quitarnos ciertos mitos de la cabeza
como la idea de que experimentar es
desperdiciar el dinero es botar la plata
todo lo contrario como ciudadano yo
preferiría que una institución pública
pruebe
validez de este experimento antes de
escalar alguna iniciativa para que
podamos hablar un montón de recursos
sabiendo que realmente lo que se va a
escalar va a servir imagínense ustedes
qué interesante sería que existiera una
dinámica en la que cualquier iniciativa
antes de convertirse en ley de la
república ser ratificada o emitir en una
política a nivel nacional tuviera que
pasar por un proceso de experimentación
para poder validar que realmente va a
funcionar y nos tenemos esperando cosas
que no en resultados
pensemos en cuántas ideas cuántas
propuestas súper interesantes de la
ciudadanía de empresarios de
emprendedores se pierden año con año
porque tienen ideas súper interesantes
que las instituciones no saben qué hacer
con esas ideas y no están diseñadas
tampoco para tomarlas o probarlas y
testear las los laboratorios de
innovación pública son espacios donde si
podríamos tomar estas ideas probarlas
experimentar las voy a mostrar con
criterios técnicos si podrían funcionar
o no todos podríamos involucrarnos en
procesos de diseño de soluciones
creativas a los retos del país en
cualquier ecosistema de innovación al
que ustedes vayan se evaluará muchísimo
el fracaso
y saben por qué es porque fracasar es
parte fundamental del proceso de hallar
nuevas soluciones uno de los beneficios
de la experimentación es que nos permite
equivocarnos rápido y barato en pequeña
escala cuando estamos diseñando la
solución y no darnos cuenta cuando ya le
hicimos a gran escala que no funciona
que no da resultados
vean por ejemplo su dispositivo móvil no
importa el que sea como que yo tengo acá
no importa la marca no importa el modelo
yo le garantizo una cosa esa versión que
ustedes tienen no es la primera que el
departamento de i + d + hizo todo lo
contrario la última antes de esta
versión hizo otras versiones mucho más
rústicas mucho más sencillas las probó
la exposición o trató de ver con
usuarios cómo funcionaban o no
funcionaban antes de mandar a hacer
miles o millones de esos y venderlos por
todo el mundo porque porque si no sería
demasiado riesgoso podrían perder un
montón de dinero tratando escalar algo
que no sirve a mí me llama la atención
como tenemos clarísimo que esto funciona
perfectamente en el sector privado nada
se escala a grandes volúmenes si no fue
testeado o probado en pequeño
pero creemos que eso no sirve en el
sector público y lanzamos grandes
iniciativas que no fueron bien diseñadas
para mí los laboratorios de innovación
pública son como esa escuela de fútbol
donde podemos llevar a los jugadores
para que prueben para que practiquen
para que entrenen para que mejoren antes
de escalar los la primera división no
todos pueden convertirse en futbolistas
profesionales o por ejemplo esos
simuladores de vuelo donde los pilotos
prueban miles de horas antes de tomar un
avión real saben cuál es uno de los
visuales problemas que hemos tenido
durante décadas que hemos escalado a
nivel nacional iniciativas programas
proyectos sustituciones las hemos
ratificado les hemos dado por ley
recursos y no fueron en la escuela de
fútbol ni pasaron por el simulador y hoy
está ahí utilizando recursos y no
necesariamente están resolviendo los
problemas que deberían de resolver para
que esto no siga ocurriendo hace unos
tres años
promovimos la creación de la mesa de
innovación social en presidencia como un
espacio para empezar a experimentar y
atraer metodologías de innovación social
al gobierno una de las primeras
iniciativas
hicimos fue experimentar con reto país
junto con impacto era básicamente una
iniciativa de innovación abierta donde
cualquier ciudadano podría traer
soluciones a una serie de retos públicos
que habíamos identificado pensamos que
íbamos a recibir más o menos unas 200
propuestas para sorpresa nosotros
recibimos más de 1.000 propuestas de
ciudadanos deseosos de participar de
colaborar de involucrarse en resolver
problemas públicos la gente quiere
participar gracias a esta iniciativa y a
otras ya estamos trabajando en crear el
laboratorio nacional de innovación
pública pero hace falta una única cosa
para que esto realmente funcione hace
falta que ustedes que sus amigos que sus
vecinos que sus colegas que sus
compañeros que todos como sociedad
realmente entendamos el valor de la
experimentación pública y le exijamos a
las instituciones que prueben que
validen que te estén antes de escalar
alguna iniciativa para que nos
garanticemos a hacer el mejor uso de los
recursos que al final de cuentas son los
impuestos que todos nosotros pagamos
quizás así logremos empezar a cambiar el
discurso
y escuchemos en las próximas elecciones
decir a los candidatos que si estamos
para experimentar muchas gracias
[Aplausos]